the memory that stays with me are five
coffins with the union flag over them
and the helicopter coming
and the dust and the sunset
was there in afghanistan that was in
afghanistan
that was hard to deal with
because i'd been there with them men
i was part of that explosion
[Music]
can you tell me what was your childhood
like
basically in life some parents are just
not meant to have children and
unfortunately my parents did they had
five children and
me dad
not i've ever called him that was never
on the scene
he just wasn't interested uh and the
mother then she um unfortunately she
suffered with bipolar and schizophrenia
so she ended up in hospital and then put
on top of that five children put into
the system
and then scattered around the country
it's a lot for any mother to
emotionally have to try and hold on to
and then the system telling her what to
do and where to go and how to behave
the first three brothers were split up
and
i don't know where they were because i
was still just a baby
and me and my sister ended up moving
around
the country
um
[Music]
ended up in
elton was the first children's home or
foster home if you like
abuse happened there
by the time i was um
10 years old i'd already had a golf club
at ramyad
and then i had to leave that foster home
i ended up down in peckham lewisham in
different homes this is with my sister
as well and abuse took place there as
well
but at the time i was 16 i um
i was in london and i was getting myself
in more trouble seeing things that i
shouldn't be seeing
and i think i was just wandering around
trying to find a bit of cash in hand
work
i was just trying to find a bit of cash
in and work and i ended up over
trafalgar i was really depressed my
jeans
were dirty i was smelly i was sleeping
rough my belly was hungry like so hungry
my legs were tired my mind was just
boggled because i wanted more of my life
than just
what was happening and uh i see this
this soldier walked past me look you
know what i mean
he looked smart look anthony looked
strong there was a bit of a swagger
about him the way he was no noticeable
yeah give it a chance why not take the
risk or lose the chance
and i signed on the deadline
i joined her majesty's rifles which is
an infantry battalion or an infantry
regiment
and i ended up in uh yorkshire to do my
basic training
northern ireland and then afghanistan
and by the time i was 20. what did army
teach you
respect independence
they taught me success
it taught me how to be fearless it
taught me
how to love when i never had love in my
life
what was the toughest thing you've
experienced in the army
the memory that stays with me are five
coffins with the union flag over them
and the helicopter coming
and the dust and the sun setting
was that in afghanistan that was in
afghanistan
that was hard to deal with
because i'd been there with them men
i was part of that explosion
can you walk me through the day
when you lost your side
it was operation pamphlet
and it was operation named
herrick 10.
it was in 2009 i'd been out there pretty
much for my six-month tour
we was in a fob called uh fob leaning
forward operating base
was in the front line there um
and basically
i had to go down the same road which was
called pharmacy road
and this is where we lost five lads and
several wounded and other people had
been injured and killed on the same road
so it was notorious
and
my job would be the valonman
v-a-double-o-n
and that's to find the ieds i was first
man out last man back in
and on this day
my platoon commander
mr hillard
he um
i remember him kicking my bunk and
saying jakey i want you on this patrol i
didn't need to be on this patrol but i
was asked to go on it
and
it was another regiment coming in
and i'd made friends with this fellow
called jonathan young from
i think i think it was of the yorks or
the merchants but he'll have to forgive
me for that one
and they were leading the patrol
and i was good at my job as a valon man
leading men bringing them back in safe
i hadn't failed
but the one day that i wasn't patrolling
and leading the men all hell broke loose
and
unfortunately poor jonathan young was
killed because he was taken over from my
position he was still fresh on the
ground he was 19 years old
and um
yeah
there was no need to go up that part of
the dirt track because it didn't lead
anywhere we couldn't do anything with
that ground and i am i went forward to
try and assist his body there was a
small small arms contact i was injured
in the first explosion the second
explosion
then came by my platoon sergeant
my sniper sergeant paul mcaleese there
was a bit of misunderstanding between
mir mcelis and he um he tripped the
secondary device which
unfortunately killed him and then
injured me
and that's the end of my career
what did it feel like at the moment
it's going to take more than a plaster
to fix this one
it just
it just it just
you just knew
it's like you can you just know i can't
explain it it's
when mclees took that that that that
move i just knew what was coming
it's milliseconds and your brain is
registering it but it's not the body
can't do nothing about it it's just
you just have to accept it
there's smoke there's dust there's sand
there's heat there's blood there's guts
and then you've got an earpiece in with
people screaming at you
and then you've got people on your flank
screaming and then there's contacts with
the
gpm jeans
or some sort of weapon going off it's
just carnage isn't it
so what happened after the injury
talking to the lads and the ladies on
the ground
they tell me that
i was really pissed off and apparently i
casually vap myself backwards behind the
machine guns and i was
stripped down to my boots because that's
what the explosion did to me it flipped
me back but apparently i stood up and
i wasn't too pleased
that's what they tell me and then uh
apparently i collapsed lack of blood
and because the end of the day shrapnel
ripped through my right thigh rip
through my um
upper right arm
shrapnel through the nose through the
right eye into the brain
what is it they say two millimeters from
my throat
i'm lucky to be here really
what was the recovery process like
from coma
to talking
there was no dramas with that because i
was in a hospital in a military hospital
where everyone had lost arms and legs
and there was something wrong with
someone and
your mind with all the
drugs
sleeping
the routine
you didn't really get a chance to think
about it but it's only when you went
home
not that i had a home to go to but
when you was left alone should i say and
you wasn't in the hospital environment
with routine medication
the realization strikes
for the first year i actually had a bit
of sight that i could walk around on my
own
and the hospital did an operation and it
failed
so i spent a whole year with hope and
faith
to then do an operation and then being
told it was a
it was a failure and
yeah i'm not an emotional man but you
know when
you have so much faith and hope that
you're going to be able to see at least
and then you're laying in that hospital
bed and you can't use your right arm you
can barely walk
and you bring the lamp to your face and
you're flicking the light on and off
just for that glimmer of hope that
little bit there was nothing
what were the hardest things for you to
learn over
again accepting who i am and what i am
um
and i'm never going to be what i wanted
to be i have to be this whole different
person now so
i'll give you an example i've got a 10
year old son i've never seen him
he's the only reason i'm living
he's the only reason for existence
because as you can probably imagine
it's um
it's quite hard sometimes when i'm
fighting my own ptsd
but you don't have to just keep thinking
that
that's a little man that needs me and i
will keep fighting
and that's that's just it he's just
he's my hero
so in terms of support for the veterans
do you think enough is done or not
really well support
it takes six months
to go from civvy to soldier but only
takes five days to go from soldier to
civi
there's obviously something very corrupt
in that isn't it
and that's the problem we've got on the
civ on the streets now with so many
veterans
they invest so much in us at the
beginning from civilian to veteran a
civilian to soldier with six months to a
year
but then when we want to leave and come
through the gates it's only five days
you mentioned ptsd several times can you
talk me a bit through what it is for you
it's emotions it's mental it's physical
it's
so the last time i had an outburst i was
in malta back at christmas
so
i'll give you a scenario
when you're in
on holiday you get all the walls of
white washed and
you get the terraces that go up onto the
balconies
and all that lime white washed walls and
the steps are cold well
in afghanistan there's buildings like
that as well
a power of mine there was a contact that
happened so they an idf so that's
indirect fire so that's mortars rockets
anything that can be fired over a wall
or even a grenade
so that came in and then there was a
massive contact and it's all going off
and we're inside our own fob so we've
all hit the deck
body armor and helmets on
and i remember
stacking up against this wall
and as one of the other fellows come
down he'd been pinged in the arm by a
7.62
pk round and um
if you've ever seen one of them like
scary movies where the blood goes
absolutely everywhere
and you imagine one second this wall was
whitewashed and it's all clean and
like
yeah it was just carnage all just
stripping down the wall and he's holding
onto his arm and
yeah
and then you're having to run through
that run up it and
yeah and then when i was in malta
that was a feeling obviously i couldn't
see it but it was a feeling
and the brain just triggers things it
just triggers an emotion because it's
trying to protect itself
can you talk me through the next goals
you have in terms of your achievement
so since i've lost my sight either
oh god there's a list there
i've done several triathlons marathons
your 10k is your 5ks great south run
great north run
200k walks in 24 hours
uh killer mount kilimanjaro
parachute jumps
i've fought in the ring a few times now
against sighted opponents
i've
walked uh walked across norway i've said
that now for the heroes of telemark
i cycled 500 miles in five days on the
tandem push bike
i come from a system as an orphan and
i'd have gone into the army and i'd have
served my country well and i'd have been
proud
because the people in there have got you
back and
i can cope with that but
that's not my career that's not who i am
now so i've now got to utilise what i've
got
the paralympics have got wheelchair
boxing but they ain't got no blind
boxing
so at the moment there's actually talks
and i'm actually talking to the
governing bodies at the moment
and that's all i can really say on that
at the moment but wouldn't it be nice to
set your own standards
and set up a blind boxing
i've been blind 12 years now
and i always told myself by the time
i've been blind 15 years
i'd have been to the summit of everest
and i will have three more fights in the
ring and wing myself a belt
and then i'm classed as number one then
i
and then i'll take my story to hollywood
and sell it
make millions sit back get fat
after everything you've been through
do you see yourself as a hero no
the heroes are the ones that come back
in the box
they're the heroes
they've give it all up
i've still got a fight
do you feel bitter
bitter about what
life
no not all i've got a good life
it's just made a little bit more
difficult
i'm successful i own my own company
i've got a nice lady i've got a son i've
got a roof over my head and food in my
belly god loves me so jobs are good
since losing my sight
it's taught me compassion it's taught me
humility he's taught me
[Music]
not to judge people
and we're all we're all guilty of that
all guilty that you know just because
that person's wearing
gothic clothes or wearing chaby clothes
or
you know
doesn't mean that person wouldn't help
help me you know and before if i'd start
i would have probably
not stuck my nose up in the air but just
avoided them and
walked on the other side of the road but
now i rely on all people to assist me so
i don't judge
what are you most proud of
obviously the first thing i'm proud of
is the sun you know i mean it's a
blessing it truly is a blessing to have
a child
um
he never knew me as a soldier but his
step daddy is a soldier
so the photos around the house where he
lives is um
all of my ex-partner and his new step
daddy
as a soldier and in combat some medals
and bits and bobs and he ain't never
seen me that and he's only ever seen me
as
a man with a white stick
so
although that
he step daddy is achieving in one degree
i'm achieving in
many degrees
because it's not every day your dad is
completely blind and has been warblinded
and will summit everest as the first
british war blind it so every day your
daddy gets in the ring and fights f
sighted people
completely blind or does a triathlon on
a marathon
so i just need to achieve and i want him
to be inspired that doesn't matter
whether you're able bodied or disabled
it's about ability
[Music]
i could see two guys
with a pkm
uh belt fed
um
russian machine gun
and they were hammering down on the lads
my rifle only shoots 1500 meters
so i had to
i call it lobbing
i lobbed the bullet in